The Arab Spring blossomed across North
Africa and the Middle East.
This award is for those forgotten children
who want education.
The British people have voted to leave the European Union.
Fight for your lives
before it's someone else's job.
No.
Well...
Tik Tok: ADHD in app form.
Old Town Road became the longest-running number-one
single in Billboard's history.
Avengers: Endgame, officially the
highest-grossing movie of all time.
The Emmy goes to Phoebe Waller-Bridge.
The United States of America, champions of the world.
Liverpool goal.
Trump is now ordering federal government workers to go back to work
without getting paid.
It's official:
the government shutdown is now the longest in US history.
There's no sense
that there's any room for the two sides to really
find a compromise. Both are digging in.
We have Big Macs, we have Quarter Pounders with cheese.
We have everything that I like, that you like.
The reason we did this is because of the shutdown.
We need border security. We have to have it.
Despicable living conditions, migrants
left in standing room cells for a week.
The United States is running
concentration camps on our southern border.
Special counsel Robert Mueller has
delivered his final report.
If we had had confidence that the president clearly
did not commit a crime
we would have said so.
We're going to impeach the motherf***r
President Trump is maintaining
that there was no wrongdoing on his part
in his phone call with the president of Ukraine.
A history-making headline,
the third time in history a sitting US
president impeached.
The 2020 presidential race is heating up.
Hell yes, we're gonna
take your AR-15, your AK-47,
we're not going to allow it to be used against our fellow Americans anymore.
Who can beat Donald Trump?
I have not been able to deliver Brexit.
India is counting votes for the world's biggest democratic election.
Narendra Modi has swept to a
crushing general election win.
Tensions rising between India and Pakistan over
Kashmir.
The long-planned Turkish military operation in Northeast Syria
has been launched.
Chaos in Venezuela.
Both the opposition leader and
President Maduro are calling for
supporters to protest.
We are witnessing a wave of
demonstrations around the world.
From the Middle East,
to Latin American the Caribbean,
from Europe,
to Africa and Asia,
it is clear that there is a growing deficit of trust
between people and political establishments,
and rising threats to the social contract.
The young can see what's in store,
what's lurking around the corner.
It's their future. They have every right to fight it.
A teenager from
Sweden called the voice of the planet
is ready to cross the Atlantic on a mission
to fight climate change.
The eyes of all future generations are upon you.
And if you choose to fail us, I say we will never forgive you. never forgive you
This is the start of a day of global
climate strikes inspired by teen
activist, Greta Thunberg.
You are failing us, but the young people are starting to
understand your betrayal.
A new United Nations report warns the
impacts of climate change are increasing and inevitable.
An environmental disaster with global implications.
The Amazon rainforest is burning at record rates.
New Delhi, air pollution is putting the health of millions of people at risk there.
...cyclone that has swept across Southern Africa
Kerala for a second consecutive year is battling floods in some districts.
Hurricane Dorian devastated the Bahamas.
We have seen what we thought was unseeable.
We can get married in Taiwan.
Taiwan will be the first Asian country to legalize same-sex marriage.
We are not immune to the
viruses of hate, of fear, of other.
We never have been.
But we can be the nation that discovers the cure.
The answer lies in our humanity.
The first man to run a marathon in
under two hours.
We are here and we have to do something nurturing that we respect
before we go.
To love somebody.
To take care of somebody.
Exactly what I was thinking.
To make one other person feel good.
And that just seems to make life not just livable,
but a gallant, gallant event.